[музика]
Хоча є речі які дуже сильно вражають
насправді це те що ти починаєш якось
розуміти усвідомлювати чому русский мир
прийшов чи прилетів у вигляді ракет сюди
в цю школу хоча Разом з тим
у школі навіть і сьогодні навіть
сьогодні можна побачити от подібні класи
[музика]
про таку фазу переходящий прес Золотой
Колос
Богородчанського партії України з цілком
рассовету депутатов трудящуся президио
Мариком вопросоюз робити косийского
хозяйства Ось такі
Ось такі речі тут
не закинуті десь а вони були і стояли
безпосередньо в класах на це все
споглядали діти і я думаю що якось в
їхніх Головах не могло скластися
розуміння що ж відбувається насправді
тому і найбільший парадокс який склався
в результаті це те що
там де був найбільший
найбільш зацементований В розумінні
Росії русский мир
він найбільше піддався
обстрілам знищенню знищення людей в
першу чергу тобто
висновок дуже простий Росія навіть там
де вони вважають вони вважали що це що
це ментально їхній території вони їх
просто знищують абсолютно попіл
незважаючи абсолютно ні на що тут живуть
люди тут
село з якого не виїхали люди і сюди і
вони сюди посилають ракети це насправді
їх нічого не можу виправдати Але якась
проста навіть логіка їхньої поведінки
мала б напевно оберігати цю територію
звірячий підхід
Так ми знаходимось в населеному пункті
який був Звичайно що під окупацією тому
що це територія яка станом на
сьогоднішній день вже звільнена але це
територія 20 км від кордону з Росією і
звичайно в перший день коли розпочалася
повномасштабна війна сюди зайшла
величезна кількість російського війська
але мабуть вони вважали що це їхня
територія і тут не можливо очікувати
неможливо очікувати від якоїсь противу
чи там якихось дій зі сторони України
якихось активних військових вони його
просто пройшли і тут практично не було
навіть якоїсь російської залоги Добрий
день
добрий
до повномасштабного вторгнення я
займався їй депутатом Тернопільської
обласної ради
крім того
займався в напрямку бізнесу
Звичайно що ніхто
не очікував планів було дуже багато
абсолютно інших ніж є зараз але коли це
все сталося зрозуміло що не можна було
стояти висторонь відповідно потрібно
було діяти і знайти себе в тому щоби
якийсь спосіб
прийняти участь в захисті нашої країни
тому я думаю сьогодні всі відповідальні
чоловіки
[музика]
практично цим займаються це Насправді
такий внутрішній відчуття моменту коли
ти розумієш що напевно тут ти важливіший
і якщо хтось говорить що там від однієї
людини нічого не залежить насправді з
такою філософії Ми прийшли до того що
нікому було б захищати нашу країну
просто
[музика]
сховались від своїх жінок
на Донеччині
з 5-3 однозначно
[сміх]
в мене не було жодного бойового досвіду
Я завжди так якось не скажу що по
пацифістське відносився до цих речей але
полюванням не займався навіть ніколи
якось ставився до цього теж
сну з відчуттям того що
вбивати це погано Так але
коли ти розумієш ті загрози коли ти
бачиш що ці бузові роблять з мирним
населенням з дітьми старими людьми це
насправді просто жахає і ти по-іншому ну
типу іншому себе не можеш знайти не
можеш знайти пояснення і ти маєш діяти
ми як підрозділ піхотний В суті своїй ми
працюємо безпосередньо на лінії оборони
і звичайно що працюємо в режимі такої
внутрішньої ротації тобто
підрозділ частково виходить на кілька
днів Це може бути дуже по-різному тому
що
бувають періоди коли ми виходимо там на
3-4 дні на 5 днів буває на два дні це
все залежить від ситуації на війні
ситуація доволі мінлива і дуже часто ці
всі речі змінюються відповідно
коли виходимо на комісії Ми там
виконуємо завдання бойове яке стоїть на
даний момент тобто воно також дуже різне
Ми були вже в різних місцях є
визначена бойовим розпорядженням штабу
ділянка яку утримує наш підрозділ
Відповідно ми коли Заходимо на нові
позиції ми їх готуємо починаємо з самого
початку Тобто ми викопуємо окопи ми
будуємо бліндажі укріплення які дають
можливість нам перебувати і тримати
лінію оборони Так виглядає
Сусіди
[музика]
у випадку наступу ворога ми відповідно
введемо вогонь Ми безпосередньо
стримуємо його і зрозуміло якщо
відбувається якийсь дії активні з нашої
сторони тобто працюють дуже часто бойові
бригади Ми теж їм допомагаємо у випадку
штурмів виконуємо там певну теж функції
ми змінюємо один одного
даємо можливість нашим бійцям відпочити
це дуже важливо насправді відновитись
мати можливість
хоча б перебити в інфраструктурі де
можна
помитись де можна речі свої попрати це
те що потрібно для того щоб підрозділ
був функціонально готовий до виконання
завдань ми коли змінюємо позицію
Звичайно що ми шукаємо
якийсь варіант де ми можемо після
позиції відпочивати бо це важливо тому
що щоб була можливість хоча б там
нормально поїсти звичайно побрати речі
самим помитися тому в кожній ситуації
по-різному тому що
тут один із найскладніших моментів Тому
що тут немає практично в селі Ані світла
Ані Води немає практично нічого світло
Яке зараз це генератор і інтернет який
зараз тому тому наразі ми так пробуємо
вже там відповідно там гріти воду
використовувати те що ми можемо скажемо
так в такій короткій перспективі
вибудувати як інфраструктуру
воду привозимо з криниці
в нашому випадку сьогоднішнього нашого
перебування Саме тут то
ми шукали будинок і
попросились в людей вони нам так
гостинно запропонували Цей будинок А
сьогодні ми так навіть маємо таку
Скажімо так дуже хорошу можу сказати
дружбу ми спілкуємось з ними Вони до нас
приходять допомагають нам теж багато
чого ми стараємось також бути якось
адекватним в цій ситуації тому
Звичайно що щиро вдячність їм за те що
це їхніх родичів будинок
насправді
Ми якраз там були
[музика]
просто можна уявити яка сила удару
яка знищила
два поверхи школи
пробило два поверхи школи І завдала
такої шкоди
практично по всій школі
[музика]
тут відбувся якраз Епіцентр самого
вибуху кажуть що сюди прилетіло дві
ракети які
долетіли практично до самого до самого
підвалу
[музика]
в моєму усвідомленні Росія ворог була
завжди тобто я ніколи не толерував в
плані розуміння і сприйняття того що
Росія - це друг Росія - це країна яка
справді з якою можна налагодити якісь
зрозумілі стосунки і відносини і ми з її
сторони не будемо відчувати ніякої
загрози Я завжди розумів що це загроза
яка не дуже не хотів вірити що це може
реалізуватися Але
станом на сьогодні ти Абсолютно розумієш
що якщо ми не вирішимо сьогодні це
питання
військовим шляхом то через років 5 знову
прийдеться комусь воювати нашим дітям
тим тим нашим там юнакам які сьогодні
мають по 10 по 15 років тобто ця
проблема буде вічною висіти над нами як
гіпотетична загроза нової війни
і звичайно що
війна сьогодні але ми її розглядаємо
виключно з позиції завтрашнього дня і
майбутнього цієї країни і
я Особисто я особисто вірю в те що ми
звичайно переможемо і ми маємо зробити
все можливе щоб ми стали країною яка
буде відповідним чином озброєна яка буде
все одно напевно відчувати потенційну
загрозу зі сторони Росії але коли ми
будемо міцні і сильні то я впевнений що
ця загроза більше ніколи не виникне і
вона ніколи більше не реалізується
[сміх]
Ну напевно я б назвав цю серію
тероборони на нулі є різні уявлення про
теоборону про її функції і дуже важливо
розуміти що сьогодні тероборони - це є
такий
архітектурі збройних сил України дуже
невід'ємний компонент який виконує
доволі важливу місію і досить серйозну і
я горджуся в тому що я є частинкою
тероборони є горджуся тим що я воюю з
такими крутими хлопцями які є в нашому
підрозділі